we're going to have pastor troy martinez
going to come up and give us prayer
miss dolo regan who's a member of the
mac committee we'll then we'll have
sheriff lombardo
we'll have peter guzman from the latin
chamber of commerce roxanne mccoy and
peter is the president and ceo of the
latin chamber
roxanne mccoy who's the president of the
naacp and craig knight the station
manager
of kcep and mr jose solario who's also a
long-time member of the mac committee
so if we could have pastor troy pastor
if you would come up and join us
and give us this opening uh prayer we'd
appreciate it thank you very much
thank you everybody for coming out today
and really excited to see all these
young people standing next to uh
our mba committee and uh i think it'd be
really appropriate just to give them a
big hand when you guys give yourselves a
big hand
thank you
and also all of our law enforcement
partners all of the lvmpd we want to
give them a big hand we appreciate
the sheriff and all of them for inviting
us out can we please give them a big
hand and thank them
today's a very important day and i'm so
glad that the sheriff and the public
information officer here at lvmbt and
the mac committee invited many of us to
come out here
and it's such a privilege to open up in
prayer but
it's very important to understand why we
invited the young people
why we came out with such a diverse
community and
and we got to understand just like you
heard from mujahid these are
some very important times there's a
trial going on across the nation
that will impact us all america is going
through some changes and i'm not going
to talk about
all those things but i am going to talk
about just a couple of things that we're
going to pray for
one of them is that 400 years ago was
the anniversary
of african americans coming to america
and being put in oppression or slavery
it's a 400 landmark
additionally about 40 years ago
my cousin who was put into a chokehold a
young girl
uh she died of this chokehold and left
behind two young children
and i brought a picture of her and it's
right here and i just give the sheriff
a picture of her and this is the first
time that i've ever talked publicly
about her death and she wasn't given a
trial or anything else
it was considered justifiable because
she talked too loud
and didn't obey a command fast enough
she had no weapon she
she wasn't a threat and she weighed less
than 100 pounds
so those are the type of mistakes that
we don't want to see repeated
and then again 29 years ago
almost to the month april uh of
april of the 29th of april was a 1992
rodney king riots and back then
my children were school age
just like now years later 29 years ago
i have my grandson here with me who is
in middle school
so you can see this pattern from 400
years or 40 years or 29 years
and then less than a year ago me and the
sheriff just mentioned he said when did
when was the last time we got together
out here
and it was less than a year ago that we
stood here because
on may 25th 2020
a police officer knelt on george floyd's
neck for
about nine minutes or so and then we
know that
there was protests and we know that it
does affect
metro because a police officer lvmpd
police officer
shea was shot in the neck shortly
thereafter
so it does impact us and it hurts us all
and we do care so as i get ready to pray
one of the things as a minister we
understand
and i got pastor cherry back here to
back me up if you don't believe me
is that before we can do reform
we have to repent we have to say
i'm sorry that i'm not going to repeat
this
and it breaks my heart what happened
400 years ago it breaks my heart what
happened to my cousin
40 years ago it breaks my heart what
happened to my city of ballet when i
lived there
29 years ago it breaks my heart for
shea and his family and it breaks my
heart for the george floyd
family and it breaks my heart for the
black community that is reliving
this on television every day since
monday
and we don't know how long this trial is
going to pull off those wounds
so it hurts but i would like to say
and i'll be the first to start to repent
i'm sorry to the black community for
what they're suffering
i'm sorry sheriff for what happened to
shea
and his family and by the way shea's
stepfather
was one of the very first captains in
the boldenary command
that helped us with safe village and my
right pastor cherry
and served the black community and
that's his son who's in the hospital
paralyzed
i'm sorry sheriff that that happened i'm
sorry to all the police officers
i'm sorry to these young people that for
some reason we can't get it together
after 400 years
but i figure if we start to say i'm
sorry and start to repent
then maybe we can start to reform
and we've been in this mac community and
i've been on it for about 15 years
month after month and there has been
many strides which you're going to hear
about
from some great people and i'm going to
let them share about that
but what i'd like to do now is pray and
ask god
to help us and i'm going to read this
scripture
the lord said after 400 years
i have seen how cruel my people are
being treated
i have heard them cry out to be rescued
from their oppressors and i know all
about their sufferings
god said that at one time for a people
that had been oppressed for
400 years coincidentally
the other thing is i like us to know
that the bible says
clearly that we were all created
in the image of god and it doesn't say
what color
we were all created in the image of god
so saying those two scriptures i like to
bow our heads
and let us pray lord we come before you
right now we thank you for your mercy
and your grace and your patience with us
as a people
as a nation we come before you lord i
ask for
law enforcement to be lifted up before
you for wisdom
guidance protection for their families
i pray for our sheriff and all of the
staff here lord that you give them
wisdom and understanding how to work
with the community
i lift up the black community i lift up
every race right now lord
i specifically pray for these young
people that they will see this turning
point
let las vegas be the place where you
smile upon us where you help us
where you hear this cry of repentance
and you help us to change things that's
what reform means
and i pray this in the name of the
father in the name of your son jesus
and the holy spirit and i thank you and
everyone that would agree would say
amen thank you
good afternoon everyone i am dora
legrand and before
i uh begin i have to say to the pastor i
hope it's not just
the black community that is hurting
because before he was formed in his
father's belly
and sanctified in his mother's womb he
was a human being
and so it is humans that was on the
ground
not just a black man so yes black
community is hurting but i hope that
people
who love people all over this world are
hurting as well
we as a nation as a community we're at
an inflection point right now
and metro as the sheriff said in an
article that he did back on march 12
has had not only metro but all of the
police departments across this community
have been affected affected by what took
place and it caused
change we had some things going on here
and so we worked hard
metro listened they instituted ethics
guidelines
and in those ethics guidelines it's one
thing to talk about the sanctity of
human life
but it's another thing it's another
thing to actually work towards
maintaining human life
that's what was put in the ethics
portion of the
use of force policy then you talk about
the de-escalation aspect
if you want to do anything when you're
trying to
arrest somebody you've got to
de-escalate the situation just so you
can bring some
statisticity to it you have to do that
then you talk about
putting them in a recovery position you
can't do anything when you have somebody
down with their face in the concrete
you can't talk they're going to listen
they're going to hear anything that you
have to say
and you have to call medical attention
and so we worked on those things we
worked really hard on those things
and those things um
were in custody incidents that we saw
play out not only with children there
were some things here
that took place as well that made us
really uncomfortable the fact that metro
will stand and listen
is important what impressed me more than
anything else and and i
am i consider myself to be the devil's
advocate on the mac committee
because that's the only way that you're
going to generate debate
that's the only way you're going to make
people step up that's the only way
you're going to make people change
is to challenge the system and to
challenge the status quo
and that's typically what we do and so
when
while we're doing this what they did on
september i think it was about the 20th
or the 25th
they came back with an after action
review of everything that took place
from march until june of last year i was
really impressed they did a
very thorough swat analysis i'm a
detailed person so the detail was
important to me
they did did a very thorough swallow
analysis and the sheriff said a couple
of weeks ago
we didn't do anything wrong i'm going to
beg to differ with them you did
something wrong but the fact of the
matter is you made a decision
to correct the wrongs and to do them
right and that's what's important
so we have a lot to look forward to as
we look at this trial every day
it hurts you to your heart to see what
is taking place
we have to make sure that as a community
we come
to this law enforcement we hold this law
enforcement accountable
and one of the things that i'm going to
i want to encourage us to do as a
community
is for the young people to get involved
we have a mac committee whose average
age is
probably about 50 right huh
well maybe um and that's that's fine
but at the end of the day it's the alex
bernal the craig knight summit
even though he's 50. some of the younger
ones we need you guys to come and get
involved you can sit there it's one
thing
to talk about a problem it's another
thing to help solve it
and if you aren't doing anything to help
solve it then you're a part of it
and we want to um ask you to please be
civil
let the trial play out i i'm probably
less hopeful than anyone
but at the at the very same time we need
to work within our own community
if we effectuate change here one teaches
one and who knows how far
that will go so thank you
good afternoon everyone peter guzman
president of the latin chamber of
commerce
i like what my colleague and friend dora
said about it's not just one group's
hurting it's everybody that's hurting
the latin chamber of commerce hurts with
our community
but those hurting also include law
enforcement
the latin chamber and myself we always
stand with law enforcement
because we know that there are men and
women
that while we're sleeping they're
protecting our community keeping our
community
as together as they possibly can so
they're hurting as well
so we all hurt together as a community
and while we watched and continue to
watch this trial
that's another place but we're here this
is our community
we have seen tragedy after tragedy here
and we've always come together
as a community we need to continue to do
that what i can share with you is that
i'm honored to be on
mac and i'm honored to be on it because
it's a real group of folks that are
in the trenches trying to make law
enforcement a little better
and that includes our sheriff we have
heated debates in this in this group
we're allowed to say whatever we want to
say
because we're trying to accomplish one
thing and that is a community
a community that's safer better
and it takes all of us to do that so i'm
privileged to be
a small part of that community and i
will continue to do what i can
to make sure that we're doing it a
little better
every day so thank you very much
good afternoon my name is roxanne mccoy
i am the president of the las vegas
naacp
and i would like to first give thanks to
our sheriff
for being an amazing community partner
to not only myself
but to the las vegas community as well
as the african-american community
and my mac members brothers and sisters
that stand with me and stand behind me
right now to support the efforts of
making sure
justice matters for all of us i would
like to start off by speaking on behalf
of the relationship between
the lvmpd um and
the naacp and the murder child
of george floyd at the death at the
hands
of a fire loss at the hands of a fired
police officer a little background on
lbnpd and the las vegas naacp
in 2018 2019 we received several calls
regarding the use of force in las vegas
before the death of george floyd we had
an
in-custody death of a gentleman by the
name of byron williams here locally
in our city it gave us an opportunity to
take a look at
our local use of force policy here in
las vegas
with that we have i had the opportunity
to have a conversation with our share
and talk to him about some of the
concerns that were noticed
in the videos from that in custody death
and with that the sheriff listened to
the concerns and those were concerns
that came from the african-american
community
community as well as other community
members
and we looked and we decided that there
was some changes that could be made
the sheriff with his leadership asked if
we could
work with our mac committee in which we
have formed here with us today
we all together took a look at those
policies and worked with our police
department in order to change
those policies for the betterment of our
community as a whole
we worked on some of the things that my
colleagues talked about earlier
was de-escalation the chokehold
the duty to intervene medical attention
the appropriateness of force and body
cam usage
and as we look at the trial that's
coming up or that's taking place right
now
we will see a lot of those same things
that are on trial right now today
the work was tough but the naacp
has a good respectful partnership with
our lvmpd
who was willing to sit down at the table
with us to have the tough conversations
in that for in an effort to change what
our community looks like
what it could look like and what we want
it to look like
with the upcoming trial we all witnessed
and saw that took place firsthand
the nation as well as our community
should watch listen
and wait to see if justice will be
served for our country
and our community as we witness this
process
i would ask all of us to maintain a
peaceful
a peaceful posture while these outcomes
are determined i will caution us all not
to respond irrationally
and cause more harm for ourselves we
have seen some people protest and it's
called exercising their rights
but when black people do the same it's
looked upon differently or called riots
we are all cautious and frustrated with
the system that we have known it to be
however let us try to be patient
maintain control in our response so that
we do not become part of a broken system
that will continue to victimize us this
is a slow moving process
but we in clark county have made
significant change
in our city and we don't want to undo
all the work that has been done
thus far we have all been frustrated in
2020 and 2021
about this egregious act that allowed
the world to see
what black mothers and families have
dealt with for years
justice matters health care matters
people matter
and black lives matter thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon my name is craig knight
general manager for kcep 88.1 fm
which is also known as the people
station and we have a slogan that we say
that we are one and the reason
reason why we say we are one is because
we are
we are all human beings first and
in order to get along we have to
dialogue and communicate
and being in radio that's what we do
best about eight years ago
i was recruited to be a member of this
mac committee
and at first i was hesitant but then
when i thought about it i said you know
the only way
to salvage relationships
and to better them is to have dialogue
and communication
so i joined mujihe ramadan and the mac
committee
and i found that it was very useful
and a great tool as far as bringing
understanding
to the community because we all
understand that we know
there's been this great divide and not
so great relationship
between law enforcement and community so
i felt
that being a part of mac knowing
that we can be a part of the policy
um encouraging and policy changes
that will prevent a lot of incidents and
issues that happens
in other cities that's one of the main
reasons why i joined and i see
that a lot of the policies
that we talk about
and collaborate on
turns out that every time we come up
with something
it always happens before something else
happens in another city
with george floyd for instance when that
happened
the use of force policy body cams
and other policies were already put in
place proactively
before that happened so
it's a testament to see that being
proactive and having a relationship
you can actually prevent things from
happening
before they happen and we also see that
the relationship that we have with the
sheriff
in metro in that committee and the radio
station
that we found that we're bringing
understanding to the communities we're
bringing
understanding to the point to where
we're all here to try to make a
difference for the betterment
of everyone but the only way to do that
you have to dialogue so i commend
sheriff
and his entire staff for
having us here monthly to communicate
and have an open mind to listen
to what is going on in community and
what people are thinking
and what we can do to fix it and better
the relationship
between law enforcement and community
and lastly i also like to say that
we appreciate metro because they sponsor
a radio show on 88.1 every wednesday
at 9 30 a.m called police promoting
unity
that's an opportunity to have a a
platform and a voice
from both sides to communicate and
dialogue
to bring together more of an
understanding of what we're trying to do
what we need to do and what we will we
want to do
in order to move
forward the relationship between law
enforcement and community because that's
to me that's very important we have to
have understanding between the two and i
think
what the mac committee at metro is doing
that i'm a part of
we're doing that so i just want to say
thank you sheriff
and thank you mac committee
all right thank you craig knight my name
is jose solorio
i'm a proud son of mexican immigrant
since the first latino to serve in the
clark county school board a while back
and uh i've been serving on this
committee through
three sheriffs keller sheriff gillespie
and sheriff lombardo
this committee has been effective in
communicating the needs
of the different minorities communities
within this town
and that has made a difference it's
taken a while but it's made a difference
and the reason i say that is because las
vegas
is not like other cities las vegas is
progressive
las vegas listens to its communities
so what has happened because they've
been listening we've had policies that
have been adopted by
metro we meet once a month and these
meetings aren't always cordial
they're very intense sometimes but the
purpose is for the sheriff to listen to
the communities to see how our community
community could be served better by
metro and one of the first things that
we talked about back in the 90s was
our police force needs to look like the
community
and i'm happy to report that that is
happening now
as you can tell by our young cadets
or young people behind me our
next line of officers looks more and
more like our community
so that's the first step the second step
we did was
on use of force i call it de-escalation
nowadays if you get stopped by a police
officer you're more likely to have a
positive encounter
about the issue at hand there's no time
to fear the police
the police is us we are the community
we meet once a month with the sheriff we
get things done
and we are different than other
departments
within our united states and i'm proud
to be on this committee and serve with
sheriff joe
gillespie i mean sorry
joe lombardo he went to the same high
school i did
alex bernal clark county um
everyone said some amazing words i'm
gonna be real quick this will be the
fastest 20 minutes
you've ever heard just playing
um i grew up in north las vegas i was
once an at-risk youth i was all i worked
with gangs for almost 20 years
and then i changed my career and i'm
working on recreation as uh working the
recreation senior center
i got a call some years back from mr
ramadan who said hey would you
like to help me work with the rookie
academy
metro academy and start working with
them on how to connect with the
community
how the officers can go out there and
start just get out of their car and just
start
making that connection a young man like
me from north las vegas who had no goals
no aspirations didn't know what he can
do with his life
but just the thinking there was a time
when i didn't like the police officers
because i was on the other side and now
i appreciate them more as i get older
and i'm paying my taxes
and i have kids and i have i want to i
want to contribute
but the fact that mr ramadan saw
something in me and say hey would you
come help
just talk to the officers well that led
to me not only that but i had the
opportunity prior to that
i used to work for the attorney general
of texas i used to train all the gang
officers back in texas
my job was to help them to communicate
and the fact that we're doing it here
also the fact that they took that upon
they're like hey alex we want you to be
involved with this we want you to help
that means a lot you know a lot of
officers can they can say we know what
we're doing this is what we do because
they used to tell me that the two
hardest people to ever
train are teachers and officers one
thinks they know it all and the other
ones
thinks they've seen it all these
officers here
and the sheriff here they're willing to
accept that they want to they want to
learn they want to get better and i love
that being part of the mac
just the fact that i can sit there and
listen to these people
and also they value my opinion again i
have to remember i'm just a kid from
north las vegas who went to rancho
and but it just makes me feel good and
know that
information that i get here is valued
but i can also get information and bring
it back to the community and also they
embrace that
so i thank you sheriff for allowing me
to be part of this mac and thank you mr
ramadan also thank you
[Applause]
are you guys wore out yet all right i
want everybody to come on in here real
close
i want all my devil devil advocates real
close
and i'm going to build on that
and dora get in here i want you right
next to me
all right just don't hurt me i'm not
going to hurt you
so as you can tell there's somebody
missing today
and that's representatives from the city
in the county government
this is not a government press
conference i did not call this press
conference
i actually had to ask to participate in
this press conference
it was requested by mr mujahid ramadan
as the chairman of the mac committee
to formulate a press conference and he
figured if i promoted it people would
show up
and uh i'm glad you did and the
important piece behind
this is for you to realize this is a
voice of the community
not the government it's not the voice of
the police department because
i don't want anybody thinking we're
thinking with insular
process and we continue to do things as
we've always done them
and we have not opened our eyes nor have
we listened
today is a testament to that the
opposite of that that we are listening
and all i ask to the community as we
progress
or progress through this trial no matter
what the outcome in
whether it's a mistrial whether it's a
acquittal or whether it's a conviction
that you understand that we're all going
through it together
and we asked for your what was roxanne's
word patience
we ask for your patience and having
and knowing the history of lvmpd and
we're here to
help you not hurt you and that is a
testament to what we have done so far
to build on what the imac committee
talked about
was and what i protest to
or profess to since i got elected is
change
and for us to be successful in our
community similar to what jose mentioned
the police department looking like the
community we have to accept
change and i am proud to say as your
sheriff
that i have effective change and i will
continue to do so
as long as i am your sheriff so thank
you everybody for coming and what i
would like to do is matter is pro call
because it'd probably be hard
to answer questions as a group this will
be the conclusion of the press
conference
and then i will let you have access to
anybody you may want to talk to
okay thank you
[Laughter]
ramadan i'm the facilitator of the mac
committee we also co-host police
promoting unity every wednesday that
craig knight talked about it's a good
partnership
one of the few police departments if not
the only police department that has
a radio program that educates the
community and the community educates the
police department
we also have former chief of the city of
las vegas fire department dave
washington's departed dave raise your
hand here
dave is also part of the mac committee
it's wonderful to have these type
resources
and the wide range and diversity of
people that we have so this does
conclude this was an mac
press conference with the sheriff's
support and all the mac and we have
probably another 20 plus members who we
didn't invite to this but we wanted you
to
hear from the people who are directly
involved we've launched two new
subcommittees
one on recruiting one on mental health
and homelessness and one on reductions
of violence so
this mma committee is taking a stronger
role
in terms of the policy developments that
have been very effective with this
department and is excellent having the
relationship with the sheriff
and his executive command the mmac
commitments are available for you
after the press conference is over and
this brings it to a conclusion
thank all of you for coming out thank
the mac committee
and the yeah bringing attention to
everybody that point dura legrand who's
also just a very
excellent resource for us all and uh as
you all know carla
alston is leaving us now but we're in
very capable hands and carla let's
give carl a round of applause she's been
such an excellent resource
she's retiring the sheriff says that
she's independently wealthy i think she
received a major inheritance from
someone in her family so
she's going to say bon voyage too but
thank her and the good work that she's
done here
we can keep building on this so this
concludes the press conference again
thank all of you
and you have access to with all the mac
members again raise your hand
so you have access to them and let me
thank the eagles christian
uh family center and the youth
empowerment for summerlin for coming out
and being a part of this press
conference you are not the future you
are the now
and with metro is truth trust and
transparency
this department does it well the
community's involved thank you all very
much